no one has been asking why we have not
been covering the World Cup on the
Michael Knowles show the answer to that
question though is that there is an
entire sister Network here that deals
with these sorts of really meaningful
sports questions that of course is daily
wire too and so I've got answers to the
questions that nobody is asking before
we get started this video is brought to
you by Black Rifle coffee more from
Black Rifle coffee in just a little bit
we turn now for the absolute most
up-to-date coverage on the soccer games
that I assume are happening somewhere in
the world we turn to daily wire 2 and
our correspondent Jeremy the god king
boring
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
will you do the Fandango Michael
enormous news from the bear of the north
as for the second time in less than a
century Germany's dreams of global
Conquest collapse in Western Russia with
their 2-0 defeat at the hands of South
Korea a nation with roughly half of
Germany's GDP speaking to the BBC former
German champ Jurgen Klinsmann said quote
it's always difficult when you win to
repeat it four years later and
admittedly strange declaration from a
nation that has made failure look easy
in every generation since the
franco-prussian war of 1870. of course
Germany who brought us the fall of Rome
the Dark Ages nihilism Nazism two world
wars trance music and the failed project
that is the EU is never truly defeated
and will undoubtedly Rise Again from the
ash sheep of history and prove that they
can in fact put a small ball roughly the
size of a human head through an enormous
net without the use of the hands that
God gave them as well as any third world
nation or France
in other World Cup news this week marks
the close of the tournament's group
stage and the beginning of the
quarterfinals what this means is frankly
anybody's guess this sportscaster for
one stop reading the Wikipedia entry
pretty early on if I'm being honest
because as a God-fearing American I just
couldn't be moved to give a flip about
what kind of archaic rules govern this
socialist non-sport uh having far more
exciting things to do with my time like
dozing lightly in my armchair or
literally anything else I did ask
several people in my office who have
repeatedly assured me that I'm wrong to
criticize so beautiful a game if they
could give me a quick rundown of how it
all works before air time but they all
reluctantly confessed to never having
actually watched a match before the
current World Cup started even though
they think it's hugely important
cultural event and I should be ashamed
of myself for blowing it off as nothing
more than a deliberate attempt to reduce
America from its status as shining City
on a Hill down to parity with the lowest
common denominator equatorial hellhole
from which the soul of man used to cry
out for freedom and deliverance to sow
greater nation is this but who now see
that we're not really all that great if
you really think about it because
without our hands and the complexity
with which we conquered War poverty
disease and death since the last World
War we're really just like everybody
else
also men are not stronger than women the
Millennium Falcon was never all that
fast and Batman could totally take
Superman in a fight even though the
latter is invincible and can literally
shoot laser beams at the speed of light
from his eyes from space a place that
none of the countries that have ever won
the World Cup have ever been to
probably probably because they haven't
figured out how to use their hands
to be clear
to be clear however it's not the
position of this uh self-entertained
journalist that the admittedly handsome
men who run around and fake injuries on
the soccer field are not athletes on the
contrary they are clearly quite fit and
able to run around if aimlessly for long
periods of time with no breaks the issue
is not that they aren't athletes it's
that soccer is not a sport it's an
admittedly mesmerizing bit of
choreography in which colorful objects
move back and forth across your screen
and then nothing happens here's a clip
of one of the weekend's more interesting
matches by way of example
laughs
mesmerizing that's it for this week's
World Cup recap Michael scaramooch
Scaramouche will you do the Fandango
back to you Jeremy that was such an
informative uh recap of the World Cup I
really appreciate that you know we were
talking a little bit there about a
Germany's strategy I was under there you
talked about that
I was under the impression that a
Germany's strategy was to have their
competition in the World Cup last a
thousand years but it seems to have been
cut short should we fear the uh the the
German soccer team rising up again
within say I don't know four to seven
years well Michael historically they
always have uh fortunately for us the
brave men and women of Western Europe
who formally gave the world the British
Empire and complex manly Sports such as
cricket and Wealthy Sports such as Polo
will undoubtedly seek a peace for our
time and appease Germany all the way to
Future catastrophe one does wonder if we
should just dismantle the German soccer
team once and for all but it seems to me
that the International Community just
won't let that happen oh no no they have
the right to Pride as a nation and we
shouldn't stand in their way all they're
looking for is a little breathing room
that's absolutely right you know Jeremy
we've we've heard a lot of from the left
about how awful Russia is these days and
and the United States colluded with
Russia but their host this most
wonderful and important International
sporting event shouldn't we just give
them a free pass well obviously this
sportscaster doesn't know much about
politics but I will say that of all the
things that Donald Trump has done that
have offended uh those in the former
never Trump contingent perhaps winning
the World Cup for the United States
America eight years hence is the worst
and the greatest proof that he seeks to
follow in the footsteps of mass murder
of Vladimir Putin in reducing the world
down to a sort of pre-civilizational
Hell uh from which even Jordan B
Peterson's philosophy may not be able to
save us I'll have to reread Alexander
solzhenitson it's been a while since
I've gone into Gulag archipelago Jeremy
the god king boring from daily wire 2 a
very important update and basically has
convinced me now to go never Trump
Jeremy thanks for being here we'll talk
to you soon Scaramouche
get back to what we were talking about
in just one second first though Black
Rifle coffee is helping you knock out
your Christmas shopping with a ton of
fabulous new products this year shop the
best Brewing gear thermoses mugs and
apparel designed for folks who love
country and coffee Black Rifle sources
the most exotic roasts from around the
globe all coffee is roasted here in the
U.S by veteran-led teams of coffee
experts stuff your Christmas stockings
with the latest roasts from America's
coffee for 10 off with my code Knowles
kwles better yet sign your Secret Santa
up for a coffee Club subscription
imagine the joy of a pre-scheduled
coffee delivery at your favorite roasts
when you need the most it is the gift
that keeps on giving Black Rifle coffee
company is veteran founded and operated
they take pride in serving coffee and
culture to people who love America every
purchase you make with Black Rifle helps
support veteran and first responder
causes go to Black riflecoffee.com and
use promo code Knowles kwles for 10 off
coffee Coffee Gear apparel or when you
sign up for a new coffee Club
subscription that's black
riflecoffee.com promo code Knowles
Canada WIS for 10 off Black Rifle coffee
supporting veterans and America's coffee
daily wire 2 Sports correspondent Jeremy
the god king boring
[Applause]
[Music]
yowza thank you Michael it's great to be
back with you for a segment one YouTube
commenter observed that's coming off
more like ignorance than humor that's
our daily wire 2 coverage of the Fuji
Water World Cup let's get right into the
action or what passes for Action in a
sport where the tide game can be
resolved by giving two teams yet another
opportunity to tie
that however is not what happened in our
first story of the week that is host
Russia's humiliating defeat at the hands
of their former socialist proteges
Croatia after a tied match Michael it
all came down to the shootout in which
each team was given five penalty kicks
to determine the winner it's actually
the most eventful and near stimulating
moment in any soccer match which raises
an obvious question since any tie is
statistically indistinguishable from a
0-0 score which is how every game begins
why can't we just skip the entire
deathly Dole Affair and go straight to
the shootout in every soccer match of
course that would admittedly make soccer
feel like a completely frivolous
non-game in which the winner is
essentially determined by luck which I
believe is the answer to YouTube
commenter mikey87's question of the week
quote
WTF does GDP have to do with anything
comma it's a sport exclamation mark
well you're half right mikey87 as Russia
found out the hard way by being unmanned
by a nation with roughly three percent
of their gross domestic product also if
you skip the entire match where would
you put the funny commercials oh that's
right there aren't any funny commercials
in soccer since no human being anywhere
on Earth has the kind of willpower and
discipline over their attention span to
actually wait even longer to see what's
going to happen in the next slow-moving
children's game in which not a single
thing has ever happened since that one
guy was heard ironically while faking an
injury in 1957. also most people for
whom the Dreadful exhibition is their
only Escape don't have the individual
income to purchase things in the first
place
still the biggest news of the week at
least for anglophiles was England's
defeat of Sweden both in GDP 2 trillion
to 511 billion and in gameplay 2-0
that's right England has officially made
the semifinals bringing their number one
best-selling single dream one step
closer to reality it's coming to the
house
of course I know that many of our
viewers as proud and patriotic Americans
are wondering why we here at the daily
wire 2 haven't devoted a bit more time
to covering America's standing in the
current worldwide tournament
we too have been confused as to why we
haven't seen Old Glory waving above more
matches fortunately angry YouTube
killjoy morosa pointed us to the answer
with this edifying comment
quote clearly you're triggered because
the U.S couldn't qualify against the
likes of Panama and Trinidad and Tobago
LOL
candidly morosa this Sports journalist
had no idea as I liked almost every one
of America's native sons who didn't grow
up doing missionary work in the third
world were being a girl never
contemplate never contemplated this
farce of a competition even once since I
was five years old and learning basic
motor functions I am however certainly
triggered now that I know you mean to
tell me that despite having a GDP equal
to 25 percent of the world's total
economy owning the world's Reserve
currency having the finest athletes in
the world as evidenced by almost every
metric including having won more medals
than any other country in the Olympics
by double having the longest enduring
constitutional republic in human history
and having almost single-handedly
invented all of the splendid wonders of
modernity and having kept the free
nations of the world largely safe for
more than a half century America can't
beat a Caribbean island nation with
fewer than a million and a half people
and a GDP lower than that kid who
invented putting pictures of your food
on the internet for people to like why I
dare say one begins to wonder if this
whole soccer business is even a fair
measurement of human accomplishment at
all Michael yeah
well a really thorough report Jeremy I
really appreciate that I I was wondering
would you say you spent more time
looking at the YouTube comments on our
segment or watching the World Cup
yowza back to you
terrific well I can't wait for the next
update I do have to ask as I think are
all red-blooded patriotic Americans how
much longer is This World Cup going to
go on hell if I know Michael yeah
well I gotta tell you I I sort of Hope
This World Cup keeps going on and on
because
I I really these these segments have
really kept me so abreast I feel like
I've learned something in every single
one and I and I hope the rest of our
audience has finally learned something
too uh Jeremy Jeremy the god king boring
everybody see you next week
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]